for now orkomana joins us live in the
newsroom with a closer look at
the trump team's efforts here in the
silver state orco
well sasha president trump as you saw
there is speaking to a crowd of
thousands of supporters
at the carson city airport he took the
stage about a half an hour ago
the president touting his achievements
in the white house while also
slamming joe biden president trump was
greeted by loud cheers as he got on
stage this afternoon
at the outdoor rally the president
continued to focus
on what he considers his greatest
accomplishment as president
boosting the american economy he said
before the kovan 19 pandemic the economy
was thriving
and trump also said with this year's
election the american people have a
choice between
what he calls a trump super recovery or
abide in depression
he even mentioned wanting to fully
resume the hospitality
and tourism industry here in nevada
president trump's visit comes as early
voting kicks off across the state
and with election day just over two
weeks away 16 days from now
we're going to win the state of nevada
we're going to win
four more years in the white house and
we're going to keep it going
early voting is underway so get
out and vote the president
also touched on his recent battle with
the coronavirus
he said after getting treatment he quote
felt like
superman trump also attacked joe biden
and spent quite a bit of time
talking about biden's son hunter biden
now the nevada state democratic party
released a statement about trump's visit
to nevada
saying in part quote instead of pulling
another campaign stunt trump should
focus
on getting relief to nevada families who
are suffering because of his
failure to lead end quote live in the
newsroom tonight orca mana 8 news now